so now we have more of a sense of what's
going on with the politics but what
about the economics well here there's a
couple of things to look at first of all
how do people view the uk uh as an
investment now you can get a sense of
that by looking at what's going on in
currency markets remember during brexit
how it was kind of going around up and
down depending on what was going on with
that roller coaster well here the funny
thing is it was moderately stable in the
last few days really weak the pound
right now against most other currencies
but it didn't seem to be moving until we
got that news that boris johnson was
going to resign when that news broke
just look at what happened to sterling
against the dollar it shot up and now it
is a fair bit stronger than it was
before so there's a bit of kind of
stability premium there people relieved
that we know a little bit more about
what's going to happen now but of course
the big question is what are they going
to do about economic policy what can
they do and one of the big things they
want to address is this both the
chancellor new chancellor andy boris
johnson have talked a lot about the tax
burden and the fact that is getting up
to the highest level that we've seen
since the 1940s that's the rate at which
we pay tax basically as a percentage of
gdp and look at how high that's going up
but here's the issue they want to cut
that but for some people the pressure
might be in the other direction the
office of budget responsibility they're
the people the government's kind of
official forecasters they produced this
bit of analysis just now looking at the
change in long-term deficit as a result
of things happening recently so
basically the higher these bars are the
more the deficit is going to go up you
can see the fiscal position actually
that's improved a bit recently but look
over to the other side so demography is
a bit worse so fewer people being born
so less people to to pay taxes net zero
the cost of net zero means that fewer
taxes are coming in petrol taxes uh and
then you've got social care and other
factors as well and you stack all of
that up and you're talking about quite a
lot of extra costs in fact
about 37 billion pounds worth if you
wanted to get net debt so the total
national debt down to the levels it was
before the pandemic you need to raise
taxes by 37 billion pounds not cut them
and that is a lot so that's one concern
uh for the prime minister leaving aside
whether he's actually able to pass any
of his legislation but overshadowing
everything is this inflation this shows
you the inflation rate across the g7 so
major economies around the world
everyone thought that we had tamed it
that it was going to be low forever and
look at what happened it has risen to
the highest level that we've seen since
the early 1980s and the uk that red line
is the highest of all so it's that cost
of living crisis that is going to remain
the big economic challenge in the next
few months